hey guys it is Monday the 17th of August
today my name is Jess McDowell and I got
a bunch of GS news all ready to go seems
that Windows 10 may have the ability to
find and disable pirated games on your
system although at the moment we're not
completely sure what content they'll be
targeting in Windows tens recently
updated and user license agreement
section 7 B revealed that we may
automatically check your version of the
software and download software updates
or configuration changes including those
that prevent you from accessing the
services playing counterfeit games or
using unauthorized hardware peripheral
devices recent reports have suggested
that this may refer to Microsoft
services and not to the Windows 10
software itself which would mean it's
designed to protect against illegally
obtained Xbox Live and Windows Store
content and not all pirated content
gamespot have contacted Microsoft for a
clarification 343 industries have yet
again addressed the lack of split-screen
in halo 5 Guardians Halo franchise
development director Frank O'Connor took
to Twitter to apply to a fan who tweeted
out hashtag bring halo 5 split-screen
back O'Connor responded by explaining if
we could do it we would do it but it is
what they call non-trivial in July 343
industries exec josh homme said the
decision to drop split screen for halo 5
was very tough but necessary to deliver
the best possible experience halo 5 is
due out on October 27 for Xbox one
finally we got some new details on the
next Mass Effect game and here's the
stuff you wanna know about that finger
development director Chris wind told the
fan on Twitter that the combat will feel
similar to the combat of mass effect 3
saying that there will be some new
elements that make it more dynamic he
added that Andromeda unsurprisingly
won't feature familiar faces from the
previous Mass Effect game since it's set
in Andromeda a whole different galaxy
either way windsor's fans of the series
will feel at home
thanks to familiar elements like the
maker and some of the same alien races
we've seen before I where is currently
casting voice actors but when confirmed
that we won't be seeing any new gameplay
anytime soon Andromeda is due out in
fall 2016 let me know down in the
comments what you think about Windows 10
checking your system for pirated games
you can get the game spot we've got
stories on the witcher 3 new game plus
mode and the final resident evil movie
those are all the things that I have for
you today let me know what mattered to
you and I will catch you again tomorrow